je regarde les jets d'eau il y a du
soleil
[Musique]
on revient tout à l'heure
Joe Dassin je vous admis vous avez une
façon vraiment toute personnelle de
résoudre le problème de la circulation à
Paris non c'est ça n'est pas à moi ça je
vais vous dire je l'ai vu je l'ai vu
faire à New York et j'ai admiré ça parce
que vous êtes de New York
vous êtes américaine et à New York
américain et à New York et alors comment
expliquer vous le fait que vous parliez
aussi bien le français
racontez-nous d'abord vous me faites
plaisir en disant ça
et deuxièmement c'est pas sorcier je
suis venu ici à Paris pour la première
fois quand j'avais 10 ans 52 pour faire
vos études
non je suis venu mes parents comme tout
gosse de visa et vous allez étudier le
français au lycée ou l'avez appris
simplement parce que mes parents m'ont
mis dans une école française
[Applaudissements]
de temps en temps comme une sardine dans
une boîte c'est bien vu avec le trafic
qu'il y a beaucoup ça on n'est jamais
nerveux
si ça
vous calmez je ne suis pas très original
je fais comme tout le monde je marche de
loin en large je gris des cigarettes je
bois si peut-être il y a une solution
insolite je pense
et mes
ça m'avance à quoi
si on utilise le mot folklore tel qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui oui mais elle vous
plaisent quand même ah oui forcément je
les chante
et voilà le feu vert qui vient de se
rallumer je passe la première et chacun
de son côté un signe de la mer au revoir
et à demain
il fera soleil
bye bye
ciao ciao
[Musique]